petit retour dans le temps aujourd'hui à
la fin des années 70 des chercheurs
avaient découvert que certains animaux
n'étaient pas assez en forme pour les
besoins de la science
on avait donc mis des vaches laitières à
l'exercice forcé
[Musique]
ce n'était évidemment pas le programme
d'entraînement du canadien mais c'est de
l'exercice et ses vaches de l'université
de utah retrouvent leur forme
la société moderne semble-t-il menace
les habitudes quotidiennes de ses vaches
laitières qui avait pris l'habitude de
paître sur des milliers d'hectares et
qui mènent aujourd'hui une existence
confiner les vétérinaires de
l'université de utah ont donc inventé ce
carrousel qui pousse les vaches à
marcher à des vitesses allant de 2 à 4
milles à l'heure rabat l'un des
spécialistes en recherche des tiers de
déterminer quelle vitesse optimum les
vaches doivent atteindre afin de
produire le meilleur relais possible
jusqu'à maintenant les résultats sont
prometteurs
après seulement quatre semaines
d'exercices ses vaches ont produit plus
de lait qu auparavant et cela avec la
même quantité de foin et birette en plus
elles ont plus donné naissance à leur
vaut plus facile aujourd'hui on a
abandonné depuis longtemps l'idée de
l'exercice forcer mes 40 ans après ce
reportage
la science n'a pas encore déterminé
quelle devrait être la durée et la
fréquence des sorties à l'extérieur par
exemple pour le bien-être des vaches
mais ce que l'on sait c'est que les
bovins comme bien des humains d'ailleurs
ne bouge toujours pas assez